alors un autre document no graphique
intéressant concernant la thématique de
la traite de l'esclavagé c'est cette
grande lithographies qui représente une
scène assez complexe où on voit tout de
suite une multitude de personnages
cette image est en fête a été réalisée à
partir d'un tableau d'un peintre
français françois auguste billard qui a
réalisé dans les années 1840 une scène
abordant la traite de l'esclavagé
alors on peut voir effectivement sur
cette image quelque chose qui est assez
complexe avec cette multiplicité de
personnages et on veut dire que
l'artiste a essayé de représenter à la
fois tous les acteurs directs et
indirects de la traite négrière
du chef africain qui vend ses captifs
eaux sub garde qui représente les
intérêts
d'une grillée et puis également tous les
toutes les douleurs des esclaves
ça va de la perte de la liberté de
l'humiliation de l'examen l'examen du
corps que des sévices avec le marquage
au fer rouge comme on peut le voir sur
cette jeune femme qui est agenouillé
également les le traitement avec les
coups de fouet on ne peut le voir sur la
partie gauche de de l'image donc d'un
côté on a le subrécargue des mêmes chefs
africains qui sont là qui
exprime à la fois une nonchalance
à maîtriser une indifférence ils sont
petits changements à billets et puis de
l'autre côté en opposition c'est là les
esclaves
qui effectivement
sont embarqués pour rejoindre le
vaisseau des grilles et que l'on voit un
petit peu plus loin qu'ils sont vécus et
qui subissent mais effectivement le
mauvais traitements et des gardiens
alors là la symbolique allait
représentait parce marins que l'on voit
au premier plan dans la partie gauche il
a ceinturé rue de haches et surtout il
tient dans sa main dans sa main gauche
défaire des entraves en faire ce qui
représente vraiment l'état de la
servitude l'état de l' esclavage ce qui
est intéressant de voir aussi dans cette
image est qu au centre il y à un
personnage l'européen effectivement qui
ressemble un petit peu à un pirate qui
en gens comme il le ferait pour un
animal le corps d'un d'un africain d'un
esclave qui est allongé sur le sol et
qui paraît totalement
tétanisée en fait là on voit
effectivement que le peintre semble
dénoncer
l' esclavage
qui transforme l'individu en une
marchandise marchandise humaine alors ce
qui est intéressant avec cette image
c'est que on a toutes les clés qui
permettent de comprendre la traite
négrière et il sent que le peintre
parmi tous les acteurs qui sont ici
représentés il il distribue un petit peu
tous les rôles et il laisse à chacun la
part de responsabilité dans le trafic